[Music]
in end of the world news submitted by
hot to play a scientist claims there's
only a worn and torn a chance that
humans will be wiped out this century
that's pretty high right I added the
only actually yeah it's just one of
twenty I was trying to be positive that
means we're gonna survive more money
that we're gonna get wiped out it's like
five percent right there's someone
trying to wipe us out twenty times it
would say pretty much twenty times for
them to wipe us out but I think about
this it's like there's one in 20 chance
that you'll die on the way home tonight
it's like oh I don't want that pretty
hot where'd you get that statists nobody
will not particularly you they actually
use a similar example in this article
it's like would you get on a plane that
has a one in 20 chance of crashing I
don't know the chances of planes
crashing to be in this so you don't know
what the base it could be one out of 50
right now and I'm just really buying
tickets all the time if it's a $30
ticket I'll take that chance how far do
I get for my thirty bucks that's what I
want to know do I get to like the
Philippines or something that's a good
gamble I'll take that piss yeah what are
the chances on a plane right now I'm not
sure no it's like one out of 20 right so
that means if there's 20 people in the
room
ones guarantee to die yeah it's way less
than one out of 20 it's got to be like
one out of a thousand but there's also
like thousands of flights a day yeah
likelihood of dying on a plane crash or
even being in one is one in 5.4 million
whoa okay what is then what is that
sounds pretty bad
it sounds pretty bad but I'm also never
died in a plane crash planes tons of
planes ever since I was a child so
playing the pretty safe anything under
one in a hundred
it maybe worries me but we still go to
Vegas are you a gambling when it's
gambling we're not gonna get shot at
again
that's what I mean it's it's it worries
me because that small percentage there's
still a chance but then in gambling
there's a small percentage there's still
a chance that you're gonna win yeah so
I'm positive about it
in both ways I'm looking at the small
percentage life is different than money
though well not to me nevermind what
does he think is gonna happen what's the
point of this what was the time frame
again within the next year tomorrow like
maybe fifty more that's the spirit but
what about the grandchildren God about
that are you living that selfish
lifestyle right now wait till you come
yeah that's they're also writing in this
article like would you send your kids or
your grandkids on a plane that has a 1
in 20 chance of crashing probably not I
guess not
not anymore do you guys know about
gamma-ray bursts right the [ __ ] is that
dude okay so get ready to [ __ ] like
you know not be able to sleep at night
so there are these gigantic bursts of
energy in the universe that travel so
fast and they're so big that we could
all be melted in an instant like like
literally in like one second from now
and we wouldn't even be aware what's
going on I just had it that sounds great
actually I would rather have that than
like a slow destruction with the fact
that that could just happen and then
we're all gone is it makes you think
that life itself is so yeah I just hear
[ __ ] like that's not like so would you
could go anytime dude you go a little
bit back on a brighter note yeah like
that can happen right right it's kind of
like when you have a like deep frying
something and it goes back so that's the
Sun just going back that's it right it's
done yeah so there's this professor of
climate and atmospheric sciences at the
University of California named Vera Baja
drawn nailed it
Ramin Nathan which University of
California's like 20 of them that's all
it's the University of California
probably the worst one they don't want
to mention is that the City one is the
shittiest was not was Riverside's just
to shake place to live in June but I
think Merced is newer than Riverside and
that became the new city all the
Riverside rejects went to your set yeah
so this professor says that based on his
calculations that if temperatures rise
greater than three degrees Celsius it
could lead to catastrophic events what's
his full studying Celsius in he's in
California the world
these are righteous are you trying to
calculate for the rest of the world yeah
but he's also trying to create findings
that no one else understands about it oh
yeah how many degrees all it speaks in
Celsius I don't know what three degrees
Celsius I think three is like huge jumps
for us three it's 37 degrees Fahrenheit
Oh God increase it by 30 degrees
Fahrenheit all be dead yeah well that's
the way it's going though based off of
his calculations the way we're going you
don't know man
[ __ ] how come you can't tell me what the
weather is gonna be in eighteen days
from now I hate those weather forecasts
they're never right yeah how about those
random days where you get your car wash
because the sunniest [ __ ] and then
randomly rains the next day what's up
with that what's up what the [ __ ]
spring that we recently had that [ __ ]
was nice we had so much rain all of our
Hills were green again it reminds me of
like what la used to look like [ __ ] 15
years ago yeah it was like that for like
eight days yeah everything died again
like everything's dead again
yeah was weird though I was like the
Irish countryside for like five days the
rings out there is crazy
it's like Meadows all of a sudden a
beautiful deer everywhere there's
actually wildlife like when you go
hiking it's not just dry fire hazard
brush there's like butterflies one here
in LA you go hiking is like chicks and
full makeup taking a
so I think you could stand to get a
little hotter melt some of that makeup
off she was really beautiful dude how
about in Russia they would [ __ ] love
it
the temperature to go up you don't say
it's always cold over there they would
love that [ __ ] yeah I feel like if the
temperature goes up 30 degrees we'll all
just like migrate to where like make
more sense rest a little cooler yeah
I'll get a pool baby is it 30 degrees
across the board yeah like the world
even the last you'll get three degrees
warmer yeah so they're saying that if
that would happen that that would be
deadly weather events like killer heat
waves hurricanes floods and droughts
anything we don't get this year now
thank God I don't wanna jinx it though
but we're getting him back to back to
back to back now right yeah they're also
saying that in the past 540 million
years the planet has endured five
wipeouts including the extinction of the
dinosaurs the worst one was 252 million
years ago and that's known as the Great
dying and that during that time it
killed off more than 95% of marine life
became acidic and so they're just saying
like the coral will survive well they
will bounce back cuz we have every time
that's okay the next generation will be
cockroaches something better will come
we'll just inhabit the souls of
cockroaches in the next time and we'll
be doing JK news as cockroaches yeah
Souls have to go somewhere yeah yeah you
know how like some parents have great
kids who like grew up to be Albert
Einstein yeah I feel like the human race
is stairs for the next cool thing yeah
and like we're just the stairs for them
to like climb on top of and then the
next cool thing will come out and the
earth will survive and be better than
ever the next thing will be dolphins you
don't think it'll be robots though it'll
be robots for sure and then don't find
us in the past and then they'll be like
you see this is the primitive creatures
but they gave us life we're already is
not breeding as much yeah and it's gonna
get way worse because [ __ ] robots are
gonna take over like I'm seriously never
dude even gonna [ __ ] Nicky again when
[ __ ] Buster I'll think about it yeah
I'm saying you can do it can't be better
than a real girl no it can't mmm thank
you for trying it well not nothing yeah
um how like it's like oh nothing can be
better than a newspaper it's like you of
the yeah you'll see you know I'm saying
give it time give it time yeah give it
time that is true ingenuity oh ya know
things will be better though things do
get that think of all the things that
you can't do to her sexually because she
has like morals or whatever you'll be
able to do whatever you want to do just
dream and she won't call the police or
anything
no yeah salt so I would just implant a
chip in here and program her to where I
control her wipe out her soul I would do
the same
yeah same because I don't think anything
will replace a human body so you owe me
for my body not for my mind I mean
that's exactly it's about time you found
out holy [ __ ] hey how about this why not
you gain 500 pounds you would have funny
feeling that I know what'll happen
I'm Gabe ten pounds not even a hundred
yeah she's the same right she the way
she treated me was like I wasn't the
same person anymore
you weren't it you were ten pounds
fatter tape see that's why I'm no carbs
right now because I'm hanging on the
edge of a cliff yeah yeah you know I got
to get it right and I'm saying yep it's
a boy works both way it does it does
well knowing this the one in 20 a chance
like that really affect the way you live
your life now like would you want to
change things in treasure I already live
in fear you can't fear me anymore I'm
already scared to the [ __ ] limit but
would you change they just keep throwing
more news at me like this is gonna
happen World War three is gonna happen
all this [ __ ] every day I'm in constant
[ __ ] worry and fear you can't you
can't push the limit what's the next
thing
I feel earthquakes gonna happen it's not
definitive enough you know it's not like
next week the world's gonna explode it's
just a one in 20 chance that's awesome
I'm just trying to [ __ ] find where
I'm gonna have my next vacation at
that's that's all I'm worried about
right now what are you watching
you know where you can get great you
want kids so you know you're not
thinking of your kids future or your
grandkids well my kids could worry about
my grandkids I'll be dead we tell you
about a great vacation destination right
now
it's called Puerto Rico cheap as hell
you can go take advantage of the Opera
that you can hit the beach there right
probably 80 bucks oh yeah you know
probably just paying for food hey guys
thanks for watching the last episode did
you love it I know you did but guess
what you can also follow us on our
personal social media accounts with the
links in the description box below so go
follow all of us now to watch more
videos talk about up there
[Music]